[Music]
check this out man harvard scientists
have built a school of fish that are
powered completely by human heart cells
wait what
i need more information before i
understand how to react
so they were able to make these fish
out of paper plastic gelatin and two
strips of living heart muscle cells that
contract automatically like this and the
fish just infinitely swims is it alive
that's the question wow i got considered
alive it's a piece of paper
does it want to reproduce that looks
like the jankiest fish i've ever seen
oh yeah is it a robot running on blood
oh oh yeah yeah because does it want to
[ __ ] say is it cardi what kind of
cells is it the heart just beats on its
own right yeah but it needs an impulse
doesn't it isn't that how it works yeah
it's technically like a biological
battery i ain't no doctor but if you
don't know like you know if you start it
it just keeps going why do they choose a
fish
probably just so
in this study they're trying to figure
out a way to just make a new heartbeat
for someone that doesn't have a heart oh
so this is like their testing because
they're saying once the cycle starts
things just keep motoring there's a
story where a doctor did that with a
lizard
and he grew an arm and he fought
spider-man
sick story bro
like that happened
yeah that's not supposed to like i don't
like
andrew garfield like that
oh you have beef with andrew garfield
i'm more you're a toby guy
you can't be a toby guy dude when he's
yeah that's the worst scene in all
[ __ ] movies ever bro
emo toby was the yeah you [ __ ]
yeah so that's their study they're
trying to explain that in some ways a
fish is a pump but instead of pumping
blood through the body it pumps itself
through the water wow
it's a robot then that [ __ ] ain't alive
i guess you could say it could be a
robot but yeah check it out basically
not our life it's hard heart cells stay
healthy by constantly rebuilding
themselves a process that takes about 20
days because the fish swam for more than
a hundred days he says each cell has
rebuilt itself in there about five times
whoa but does the cells need to eat
anything to [ __ ] oh yeah does the
fish eat that's crazy oh it doesn't swim
don't do nothing because it's just it's
just these contractions one side and the
other and it makes the tail go like
that's loco ese so the cells
like
mat that reproduce well it's like if you
think about it you know that heart
tissue so it's not just swimming through
regular water that liquid has a solution
that helps maintain it okay
yeah so heart operates like a biological
battery through the sodium potassium
pump so you got positive and negative
ions going in and out right and then so
technically it's like a potato where you
can like power a light bulb just
infinitely until
all of the ions go through it so it
lasts 100 days but i'm sure like maybe
to 200 days or whatever the heart will
eventually slow down once it runs all
the ions in the water through the tissue
um yeah basically like i know things
about yeah what the [ __ ] you just want
to know everything about hard food
oh you just made all that up
this is electron sodium pumps
now that was that was a good explanation
i just had to make fun of towers
that was actually really good
explanation i just had to make them so
scientists but i respect the hard
sciences too sometimes
i'm about feelings i don't know about
why is the heart why is the heart the
feeling thing
because that's where you got the four
chambers of anger
pissed the [ __ ] off
horniness mm-hmm and goddamn oh
greeks used to believe that the emotions
and everything was in the gut not the
heart because we felt like uh
butterflies yeah butterflies on the
stomach the gut or when you feel like
[ __ ] what did the italians say it's
probably similar we just stole a lot of
greek [ __ ] because the romans right yeah
i thought italians were the feelings
around the balls hey what you say to me
the feeling's in the finger dude
fingers
nuts
this is the representation of a ball
sack
hey what's the matter yeah
right in the testies security deposit
[ __ ] that hey i got your security puzzle
right here
you guys are like got it tell me if it's
like new york
yeah
that's all we know from tv
security
[Laughter]
yeah no they're correct how did you
react you're left
there's no such thing as a security
deposit for that reason yeah yeah
yeah
you don't [ __ ] trust me
what are you saying huh what this face
ain't a good enough guarantee
[ __ ] out of here all i wanted was you to
start
[Laughter]
so like hearts and stuff man what's up
with that
what's up with hearts and fish
yeah so that
said they don't consider those things
living beings yeah i don't either they
said they're
yeah that's what's going on crazy
it looks like it's living it does but
they said all you're doing is replacing
an engine or a rotor or another piece
that you would make in a machine that's
all it is wait was it originally a fish
no it's just a piece of paper plastic
it's like a paper gelatin it's just
pumping salt does it look like it's
living because it because you have the
contractions of those cells
he's like this is not supposed to be
alive but it's living i don't like this
little plastic [ __ ] fish that you put
in the bathtub and you can play the
with the magnets
[ __ ] plastic fish
it's just so fun to talk like that i ate
a pizza today that's why we didn't eat
italian bro you did you're the sub bro
we need a meatball sandwich yeah
[ __ ] little jelly
[ __ ] heights deli
[Laughter]
we need to have a segment where you go
like in italian news
you know what's funny is how do we even
pick that [ __ ] up when there's no
italians here in like l.a well there are
but they're on tv
do you have a little italy here no
no but you know what's funny is there
used to be like an italian community
because there's a remnant of an old
italian like
delhi
now
but it's trickled around right there's a
chain of them yeah i forgot the name of
it but it's like an italian market and
the people there or the hey what's the
[ __ ] matter here you know maybe does
something to you well like literally
little italy's in like big cities on the
east coast or straight italian food well
and they're straight italian yeah yeah
yeah do you think if not even an
italian-american accent but like italian
yeah yeah that's why my last name
like those guys they were super isolated
very italian yeah it was pretty good
do you think if la built like a little
italy do you think people would come you
think italians would come no i think it
was a time that they will come type [ __ ]
no i don't think so i think it was a
timing thing like my family floated over
in like the 20s or 30s my grandpa and
from where italy uh i actually saw their
like uh names at the uh whoa
new york
no way yeah it was cool they came to the
us first yeah and then they went to not
other side of the family so dad's sides
of town oh besides argentina mom mom was
born in argentina but that was born here
but they floated through ellis island
and then i think they just went to big
cities so dad's family ended up in
little italy and cleveland and that's
where they grew up sick but i think they
were so isolated that like
there's racism going on
like my last name is farnachi
but there's a lot of racism and stuff
and my uncle was a pro boxer and they
switched the name against italians
like like whites of them against
italians but now like italian is white
yeah yeah but but then there's world war
two and and even just americans like the
yankees didn't want to get the [ __ ]
italians out of here you know yeah yeah
so uh yeah with that our whole family
changed our name
wow just look at your pro box wasp
white anglo-saxon protestant yeah yeah
that's considered white that's a yankee
because my yeah cause my girl is like
british right she's like well she's
welsh which is real white uh classical
indigenous white home depot paint color
yeah yeah pearl white real well
it's the whitest white you've ever seen
hw here quiet
you
[Laughter]
check out this welsh girl you see that
she's like that's the way you need it so
when she when she came here she was like
i don't freaking understand this whole
like
who's white and who's not like i don't
get it yeah like even bart's joking like
italian's white but it's not white but
it is white it's like olive oil i guess
but like but then like
off white is that not white olive oil
[Applause]
american standards though you're
actually latino
yeah yeah i mean
like i'm 50 like i'm i'm i'm happy
you're argents you're the best of both
worlds yeah i am i just don't look it i
mean but argentina's but i just if you
go to europe if you go to europe they'll
consider you white yeah even when i go
to mexico i'm obviously kind of pale now
because the winner but i'll go to mexico
i went to uh with my buddy and one of my
best friends like a redhead and their
family is [ __ ] wasped out and uh we'd
go like slightly separately they'd all
try to talk spanish to me they'll try to
talk english to them
like people they could tell a little bit
that something's different well canelo
looks like an irish ginger man yeah he
looks like irish but he's mexican right
then yeah do you identify with white
i don't know man like my mom i think
probably because my mom is like
argentinian she moved here when she was
like 18. does she have an accident at
all i i so i had a weird uh epiphany
when i was in like high school
because you i just know my mom is my mom
yeah my best one of my best friends is
indian and his dad's accent's so thick i
couldn't understand [ __ ] yeah and then i
was like
he's like no he said no he doesn't i
said no bro i can't understand your
[ __ ] dad yeah and then i was like can
they not understand my mom like do i
just not know i can't understand my mom
no but then i asked my homies i asked
the homies to like no not at all she's
been here long enough i guess oh wow but
she does have an accent
is it slight i don't think so did she
say certain words differently i don't
think so i'm mistaken you called you uh
mistakenly called you white earlier i'm
not offended by anything
i'm not offended about nothing you
should try though
silent white horror figures it's healthy
yeah i don't know
yeah white mike like silent white
because it sounds like silent night
silent white half of america doesn't
even know what argentina is you know
didn't you just spell mike with three
k's too 3k [ __ ]
oh my god in my head i was like why um
[Music]
one right asian but then at the same
time like come on with like
thousands of years of different culture
like
how how do you blend it into one well
what kind of chinese are you
the ching chong kind
because
[Laughter]
i love japanese food because i like
chinese
and you're like
just saying both yeah man
he's like they're kind of the same
they're parallel
they're adjacent yeah it's not like hey
i was like hey hey
are you chinese girls yes i'm chinese
i'm like how about mexican meals no
and i'm like why you don't like mexican
he goes i'm chinese
the bar's whispering to him you're
chinese you're chinese you're not
messing around
it's [ __ ] american
hey either way both your hands know how
to make a good steak
true
we got good food we got good food
[Music]
[Music]